[Music]
tight security protests
awkward group photos and some even more
awkward handshakes
you did very well last night my god that
was a difficult one they are the
familiar
features of these annual meetings of
global leaders
what actually is the g7
well it stands for the group of seven
but it started out life
as the group of six formed in 1975
france germany italy japan the us and
the uk
were the initial members the g6 became
the g7
in 1976 when canada joined and then it
became the g8 in 1998
with post-soviet union russia welcomed
into the club
now you might be thinking hang on a
second why all of a sudden
is it g7 again well in 2014
russia was kicked out in response to its
annexation of crimea from ukraine
g7 leaders taken in turns to hold the
presidency
each year and whoever is the president
hosts the meeting
and broadly speaking sets the agenda
the leaders spend a couple of days in a
luxury hotel
in a remote location holding meetings
and press conferences
then they try and agree what's called a
joint
communique a statement setting out their
position
on things like climate change counter
extremism
or confronting global health challenges
like malaria or aids
well the short answer is no indeed in
recent years disagreement and disunity
have defined proceedings far more than
unity
that was in no small part down to this
guy at the 2018 summit in canada donald
trump arrived late
and left early he had a row with other
leaders over trade tariffs and his
desire for russia to be readmitted but i
think it's much more appropriate to have
russia in
it should be the g8 because a lot of the
things we talk about
have to do with russia he ended up
withdrawing his support for the joint
communique
now although the official member list is
currently limited to seven countries
the invite list is a bit bigger than
that leaders of other nations
often join with australia spain and
india regularly in attendance
as well as the president of the eu
commission but there are questions about
whether the g7 ought to be
more inclusive particularly when it
comes to representatives from
african and latin american countries for
that reason
the g20 is rising in prominence it's not
been around for as long
and is more focused on issues like
markets and finance rather than wider
politics
but its membership includes the major
emerging economies
of brazil india mexico south africa
and not least china many analysts
suggest that while the g7
still sets the agenda for the global
discussion
increasingly it's the g20 where the real
business gets done